Quantum Computing ist in die Ära der praktischen Nutzbarkeit eingetreten
Das bedeutet, wir können Quantencomputer einsetzen, um
reale Probleme zu lösen – auch solche, die für klassische Computer
sehr schwierig sind
Ein wiederkehrendes Muster in der aktuellen Ära ist,
dass ein Problem erstmals
auf einem Quantencomputer gelöst wird
und anschließend Wege gefunden werden, es auch auf einem klassischen
Computer zu lösen. Dieser Zyklus aus klassischem
und Quantum Computing, der beide an ihre
Grenzen treibt, wird sich voraussichtlich
noch einige Jahre fortsetzen. Es gibt Problemklassen, bei denen Quantum
Computing einen nachweisbaren Vorteil
gegenüber klassischem Computing haben kann
– vorausgesetzt, es gibt Fortschritte in Bereichen wie
der Fehlerreduzierung und der Anzahl verfügbarer qubits
Es gibt auch ganze Anwendungsgebiete,
in denen Quantum Computing
in absehbarer Zukunft nützlich sein könnte
Eines dieser Gebiete ist Quantum Machine Learning, kurz QML
Quantum Machine Learning bezeichnet
die Anwendung von Quantum Computing auf jeden Typ von Machine-
Learning-Prozessen. Es gibt natürlich
viele Arten von Machine Learning
Zwei besonders interessante Arten sind
überwachtes Lernen, bei dem du
einen Algorithmus mit einem beschrifteten Datensatz trainierst
und unüberwachtes Lernen, bei dem
der Algorithmus mit unbeschrifteten Stichproben arbeitet
und versucht, die zugrundeliegende Verteilung
oder die sie erzeugende Funktion zu erlernen
Ein unüberwachter Algorithmus könnte zum Beispiel
lernen, neue Stichproben aus derselben Verteilung zu generieren
oder herauszufinden, wie man
die Stichproben in Gruppen mit ähnlichen Eigenschaften clustert
Sowohl überwachtes als auch unüberwachtes Lernen beinhaltet oft
das Einbetten von Daten in höherdimensionale Räume
und die Manipulation von Daten in höherdimensionalen Räumen
sollte uns an Quantum Computing denken lassen
Lass mich das erklären: Stell dir vor, du willst entscheiden, ob
ein Datenpunkt aus der Ebene
als Kreis oder Kreuz klassifiziert werden soll – anhand der beschrifteten Trainingsdaten hier
Manchmal lassen sich Daten klar durch eine Linie trennen
oder durch eine Ebene in niedrigen Dimensionen
wie hier gezeigt – und diese Datenpunkte danach zu klassifizieren,
ob sie oberhalb
oder unterhalb der Linie liegen, ist
kein Problem. Schau dir aber diese Verteilung an:
Hier gibt es offensichtlich keine sichtbare Linie, die die Datenpunkte trennt
Für diese Daten könnten wir uns jedoch eine
Abbildung von zwei auf drei Dimensionen vorstellen
sodass unsere Daten nach Anwenden der Abbildung so aussehen
und es eine Ebene gibt, die die beiden
Klassen klar trennt – diese können wir
zur Klassifikation verwenden. Wenn dir das zu vereinfacht erscheint,
hast du recht. Wir können die Datenpunkte nicht einfach
nach oben verschieben, ohne Begründung
Es muss eine Abbildung geben
von der zweidimensionalen Verteilung, die unsere
Datenpunkte wirkungsvoll trennt, sodass wir
die Abbildung nutzen können, um neue Datenpunkte zu klassifizieren
Das wird ausführlicher in der Lektion besprochen, die eine Machine-
Learning-Zusammenfassung gibt – aber es genügt zu sagen,
dass das Problem sich so betrachten lässt,
dass man viele verschiedene Abbildungen in diesen höherdimensionalen
Raum ausprobiert, um zu sehen, welche
die beste Trennung von Datenpunkten unterschiedlicher Klassen ergibt
Diese Manipulation von Daten in höheren Dimensionen
ist ein Bereich, in dem Quantum Computing
große Auswirkungen haben könnte. Um zu verstehen warum,
kehren wir zu den Unterschieden zwischen klassischem
und Quantum Computing zurück. Genau wie
klassische Computer Bits als Informationseinheiten nutzen,
verwenden Quantencomputer qubits
Doch bei einer bestimmten Anzahl von Bits – sagen wir vier –
kann ein klassischer Computer jeden der
zwei hoch vier oder sechzehn möglichen Zustände annehmen
Ein Quantencomputer kann ebenfalls auf sechzehn mögliche Zustände zugreifen
aber er kann in einer Superposition aller
sechzehn Zustände gleichzeitig existieren
und Operationen können auf diese gesamte Superposition angewendet werden
Bei vier qubits mag das noch nicht
besonders beeindruckend wirken, aber stell dir vor, was mit
einem Quantencomputer mit zwei hoch zwanzig oder
zwei hoch hundertsiebenundzwanzig
gleichzeitigen Zuständen möglich wäre. Es gibt noch viele weitere Unterschiede
zwischen klassischem und Quantum Computing, die
alle in diesem Thema eine Rolle spielen
Quantenzustände haben komplexe Wahrscheinlichkeitsamplituden
Manipulationen von Quantensystemen werden mit
unitären Operatoren durchgeführt, und Quantencomputer unterliegen anderen
Arten von Rauschen als klassische Computer
Diese Unterschiede werden immer wieder
in deiner Arbeit mit Quantum Machine Learning auftauchen – in Bereichen
wie Datenkodierung, Feature Mapping und Fehlerminderung
In manchen Fällen ermöglichen uns diese Unterschiede zwischen klassischen
und Quantencomputern, völlig neue
Algorithmen zu entwickeln. Das war jetzt ein sehr knapper Überblick
über die Verbindung zweier enorm komplexer Fachgebiete
aber hoffentlich sind zwei Dinge deutlich geworden:
Machine Learning löst Probleme oft,
indem es Daten in sehr hohen Dimensionen manipuliert
und zweitens: Quantencomputer sind gut geeignet,
Daten in hohen Dimensionen zu manipulieren
und tun das auf eine andere Weise als klassische Systeme
Das sollte dir einen Eindruck davon geben,
warum Machine Learning ein vielversprechendes Feld
für die Anwendung von nützlichem Quantum Computing ist